attenzione da domani whatsapp sarà a
pagamento
se non condividi il messaggio dovrai
pagare anche tu amore fallo tu che lo
usi tanto aspetta sentire questa
angioletto angioletto che vive gli
quando vado a letto con dvd l'uomo non
ti basta niente la filastrocca per
bambini con a verduno buon auspicio
ma pietro ieri sera no vabbè che schifo
come stanno limando il video che me
l'hanno mandato via schipa riesco a
vederli allagati di tifo ma stasera cosa
facciamo io e la mia serie tv preferita
non ero io ci riusciamo assolutamente a
pizza ma che li aiuterà o dai giudici
ciao edo hai saputo della festa di marco
sono 100 euro totali quindi a testa
5 euro ok va bene grazie mi due mari
figurati
ci vediamo sabato o ragazzi sto
imparando a cucinare avete visto che
tagliatelle che ho fatto
che belle come fanno alcuni cinema e ho
cucinato con mia nonna quelle ragù alla
bolognese o poco cotto tipo 12 ore sì
quello è un giorno vuole proporre a
tutti no vabbè ma grazie per la
considerazione
insieme certo certo le foto tutte io
vedo hai visto il regalo che ti ho fatto
ti è piaciuto mi va bene allora ci
vediamo presto
sì per sé già ragazzi non ha riuscita
del gruppo no perché noi l'abbiamo
riposto aspetta creare aggiungo scusa ma
fate pure prende riflessa stasera
andiamo al cinema solo per farti piacere
forse vi fate preparare buhagiar misti
ma come stanno i miei nipotini
buongiorno nonna giorno vederlo come va
la sola scuola non tutto bene e mi metto
subito a cucinare è allora ci vediamo
domani un bacione a domani lo diciamo la
mamma saluti dei voti miei luci della
mia vita
caduti nonno giorgio
ciao edo volevo dirti che mi ha fatto
molto piacere rivederti ieri sera e poi
stavo pensando magari una di queste sere
potremmo vederci per una cena o un
aperitivo che dici
[Musica]
amo lo stronzo ufficiale ma credo l'ho
visto noi né gli ho chiesto lo so se
potevamo vederci ma di queste sere e sa
cosa ha fatto quello stronzo
cosa ha visualizzato e non la risposta e
come fai a saperlo a montebruno ciao
mani allora stasera ci vediamo
oddio amo e dove ho scritto cosa
rispondo elimina messaggio perché
deviato il messaggio no edo era per mia
mamma scusa ho sbagliato chat praga ma
oggi che fate vi sto parlando un po di
tv voi io vado in palestra poco anche
kakà kakà kakà kakà
no dai 8 ti prego anche se non condividi
con noi questi momenti va bene uguale a
cena che la faccina che ride pc magari
una moto ha iniziato la caccia a kakà
kakà cuore ma riesce a scrivere una
parola incrocio faccina che ride facendo
si comunica così ora cuore cuore
unicorno eliminiamo in album torno
unicorno unicorno gallina facile
[Musica]
da magari cambia la foto profilo
ciao e mi ha fatto un po attivamente ti
piace questa tantissimo dai mari lo sai
che ti amo è stata solo la scappatella
non voleva dire niente
non possiamo dimenticarci tutta questa
storia in realtà mi sono dimenticata io
di fare una cosa di bloccarci bello no
ti prego non lo fare l'oca punta faro e
non lo fa
purtroppo siamo arrivati alla fine del
video ma se il video vi è piaciuto
ricordatevi di mettere un belliche o
pollice in su è di commentare facendoci
sapere quale di queste situazioni
bè capita più spesso se non l'avete
ancora fatto mi raccomando iscrivetevi
al canale e cliccate sulla campanella
vicino al tasso d'iscrizione così non vi
perderete mai più nessun video e poi se
volete fare contenta nonna carmela
seguitemi su tutti gli altri social
quindi instagram tik tok e facebook va
bene arrivando un grosso bacio e ci
vediamo al prossimo video ciao